Now for both physical and mobile channels, there's an art to building a minimum viable product.
Just think about this, an MVP is not a minimal product.
An MVP is not like, well, we only have three weeks so we cut off the featured list here.
That's not what an MVP is--an MVP is based on interaction and iteration
in understanding customer's needs and pains and gains.
And if all you're doing is cutting off the featured list, then you clearly haven't run the process.
Sometimes we get, but my customers really don't know what they want.
I'm creating something so new and getting out of the building is just a waste of time because if I
show them my solution, they're not even going to know what problem I'm talking about.
We're going to be talking about the problem of market type in a subsequent lecture
but there's a case called the new market where you're right,
customers have never seen an iPhone before or never seen a new product before.
In that case, you still want to get out of the building, but instead of asking them about features,
you actually want to understand how are they spending their time now
and what solutions are they using to solve their pains and gains.
And so we'll talk about market type later but when you hear people say,
but my customers don't know what they want, just park that for a while,
because that's not an excuse to stay in the building and keep adding features.